hey everyone welcome back to the game
sports stage here at e3 2017 joining
Dave and myself to faces you might
recognize from xboxes e3 press briefing
we have Brendan green player around
himself welcome thanks very much and
Chris Charla from the idea Dex box
program
hey welcome so guys big III for idea
textbook big Z 3 for Xbox absolutely wet
should we start with battlegrounds
coming to Xbox that is a big get not
only for Xbox but it's your console sort
of premiere I guess yeah that's right
we can't wait I mean the game preview
program is great for for games like us
so we can kind of do a early access on
on console and the Xbox one X is beast
anyway so can't wait to see it all that
you guys have been doing a really great
job at supporting and and optimizing
your game for PC at least you've had
that mantra of a monthly update yeah is
that going to be the same going to
console or is it but like what other
versions always be tied together um I'd
like to think so well again I'm not I'm
not 100% on development plans for that
but you know we we have a pretty active
development we have weekly and monthly
updates and you know I'm sure that will
carry over to Xbox as well so how did
this sort of new partnership come about
like a game um you know we've moving on
the folks at Blue Hole for a little
while obviously they do Tara and
everything and and then the game's
fantastic so was over in Korea and met
up and there you go yeah so do we know
the extent of the is it going to be Xbox
exclusive in terms of consoles or is it
it's a console launch exclusive so it'll
be in when it's in Xbox game preview
awesome so I mean what are the
challenges in bringing it to console
well again it's a massive open world
it's like 8 by 8 with a hundred players
which in itself is a challenge but
unreal is a great engine for that and
like we have it running on scorpy
already and it runs relatively stable II
write like we're getting a pretty solid
30 FPS on which is like for a game that
we haven't really spent a lot of time
optimizing yeah I mean it's it's a great
start yeah for a game that's it's
obviously heavily influenced by like the
online community
like twitch you guys have been what Xbox
been talking about mixer are you going
to be implementing the whole mixer thing
with that as well and auditing elements
of that in there yeah I mean we want to
do across all the streaming platforms
you know we want to provide support for
them all I mean yeah I mean that was a
thing that you guys dropped was it this
morning that because of that that the
guy on was at YouTube who had players
like friends coming in to be zombies you
guys are now using zombies yeah so we we
saw this on YouTube for dead zombie
modes in our custom games and when we
were in Prague doing motion capture we
decided right let's capture some zombie
animations just to have it and then
myself and the animator sat down over
the three days before you three just
made a quick video showing off the
zombie animations we've no plans for
them like set plans from the airport
they'll be player controlled which is
going to be interesting you know it's
it's not just AI it's hundred players
rolling at you all right if we hope the
the element of like the twitch partners
when it comes to PC and they can create
their their custom games is that going
to be something that also carries over
to console we're going to be able to
join in with our favorite streamers mmm
doing things like that not sure yet I
mean it's it's certainly possible yeah
absolutely it's kind of thing we would
love to include and so I'm sure we all
be looking at it we want to do deep
integration with all the streaming sites
so like it is easy for content creators
to play with their their fan bases for
that and you know our partner program is
like it's not just for twitch partners
is for like community members that do a
good job and for bigger communities and
LAN events and stuff like that and you
know it's ya know it's a great way to
see what they come up with how has it
been seeing the community's reaction
when you're adding things that in any
other game might be a small change like
just tweaks to movement and weather and
the community goes nuts for it because
those small elements are actually
changing your game so much a map when
it's raining is a completely different
experience to a map with a sunny like
how does that feel oh no that's what we
want we want like that sort of depth of
gameplay that like every match you play
is different and you know with we're
adding three more weather settings in
and you know that's just again going to
guarantee that okay it's a foggy map
you're not going to be plays able to
place a sniper so much this random and
really try to get people out of there
our comfort zones challenge them in the
game yeah as a fan um it's a huge deal
right because like you play this game
totally at least I play this game
totally differently than I would play
like a traditional first-person shooter
or something like that like I'm sitting
there usually turtling hiding
thanks depending what we're doing judged
I play the same way and and just like
staring at the environment for anything
to move and so you know if it's foggy or
it's raining that actually makes a huge
difference yeah I mean I honestly can't
wait for foggy weather and zombies no
that's oh my baby
yeah very even more intense right we
play a lot in the obvious there's been a
lot of there's been a palms and shake
your hands at the end of the game
there's been some Curt words yes I am
well known for swearing at the end of a
round I apologize that sauce brings it
out on all of us yeah exactly
um how is a have you had to adapt the
game for for console when you when
you're playing on PC at least that it
feels like it's almost designed for a PC
that the way the inventory system works
the way the movement works the way
leaning around corners works everything
like that how how are you changing that
for for console is there any challenges
any tweaks you've had to make like a
game pad well notice it like we're going
to be talking with you guys about like
the best way to move forward with this
and you know we know it's important to
get a really good solid control
especially for a shooter you know you
need good movement controls of where
that I'm working with these guys I mean
they have the experience of doing it for
many other games so yeah and actually
test it on gamepad him I got a top 5
which is actually my best score ever
gotten so maybe game pads like the that
game PC players as well yeah I was
actually playing it you do fun players
the the theory of PC controls with let
me do bunkie just something to this like
I saw you out like I'm I'm a camper and
so I did quite well I got top 5 then I
actually had to like came face to face
with someone else I did not get top four
well you're gonna be implementing things
like assisted aiming for when it's very
much console then we'll probably have to
do something yeah I want to try to get
it to it like I think as a destiny I'm a
really good feeling yeah and that's the
kind of aim we're going for is that it
just feels solid you know that it
doesn't feel like cheating you know but
it feels solid you know
so with Xbox um a big thing you guys
doing these days is like play anywhere
like cross-platform play is that going
to be implemented with console version
it's up to these guys yeah I'm sure you
know I pry it I mean I would see how it
goes like it's possible the Unreal
Engine allows you to do this you know
it's possible to be cross bar but across
all platforms so you know we'll see yeah
I think there's just a lot of things
they are really about gamepad versus
mouse and keyboard that you know you
want to make sure that no one has a leg
up exactly exactly
yeah and you guys obviously you're in
early access at the moment and you've
said previously you've not really given
yourselves a landmark day it's kind of
coming out when you're happy with it and
when it's ready
but you know when abouts the console
players are gonna get their hands on it
all we said like later this year I mean
we don't want to give any certain ETA
because you know that comes with
problems you know you save this thing
and then you have to delay it so it's
later this year you know we want to make
sure that it's solid the same was like
when we were going from our closed beta
in early access you know that we wanted
like the game that was sold in early
access to be pretty stable you know and
it has been pretty stable since launch
so you know we serve to improve a lot of
stuff but that's the same you wanna go
for console make sure it's stable and
playable you know go from there yeah so
how long have you guys idea Xbox been
involved in this project is it kind of
been a secret behind the things yeah it
has been
like I haven't recur I have look
carefully not tweeted about the game
playing a ton of it and because I what I
don't want to jinx things or you know
what I mean so so it's really nice to be
able to tell the world about it and have
you on stage and it's just been really
really cool but yeah we've been we've
been fans really since the beginning so
yeah and what's your involvement now are
you kind of helping these guys develop
it for console alongside the development
for PC or is it kind of develop it BCI
then move its console these guys are the
developers and so but we're here to you
know like there's things like hey how do
what's the best practices for controller
what's the best practices you know for
lots of different things on Xbox
achievements you know all sorts of
things like that and so we're sort of
here to consult on that but we're not
the creators you know by any means like
these are the these are the guys so I
mean we have a so the Xbox version is
being done by a company called tickle
they're based in Spain they do the
character customization
system we have mutable it's middleware
and they're handling most of the Xbox
work so you know the PC version has its
own team and the Xbox version has own
team we have like our 3d replay system
in game and that has its own like we
employed a small Korean company to come
in and be on-site and do that just that
for us so you know we're we're expanding
the team to be able to do all these
projects without having to split like
you know some of the PC guys go and work
at Xbox it doesn't happen like that it's
like we have our own teams for every
individual thing so it'll be good for
development one thing I love my idea
Xbox is the variety of games that you
guys always haven't shown I think this
year's press conference for Xbox was a
great display about what
apart from battlegrounds what are the
other big wins that you guys have heard
this oh I mean there's some amazing
games I think there was um well there
was 42 games that were shown in the Xbox
previous 40 yeah only 42 and I think
more than 25 of those for ID at Xbox
games or you know titles from
independent developers and so just like
you I love the variety there's really
something for everybody on Xbox coming
from the ID program so you've got you
know games for people are really
interested in competitive multiplayer
and you've also got games like ooh
bleats which I don't know food as a
scene was just a super beautiful like I
was a cute game where you're at a
farming simulator and you're raising
these cute little animals and it's just
it's just awesome and but you know
whether it's adventure or action or
exploration there really is like sort of
something from everyone from from the
program so it's been cool when you reach
out to developers what are you looking
for you're looking for you know a game
that will maybe fill a hole that you
think the Xbox lineup has are you
looking just for that one great idea I
think we're really just looking for you
know it goes both ways we have a lot of
developers reaching out to us all the
time and then of course it shows like e3
and packs and games come and even
smaller shows you know we're out there
constantly looking for cool things and
we're just looking for things that are
going to you know honestly like delight
Xbox players and and because there's
such a variety of players that can be
anything you know it can be a really
hardcore game it can be a really niche
game it could be a game from a
200-person team it can be a game for
Micah you know one man or one woman team
and you know I wish I could tell you
exactly what the formula was for like
hey how do we find a game that we think
is really special because if I could
write it down would it be easier but
instead we just you know you you you
just know when you see them they're just
like oh like that one's got the
or something the it factor yeah I don't
it's actually quite it's quite cool to
see that other publishers are doing the
same thing you've got like the square
annex collective for example or you have
Sony's X def program what's it like and
why why do you think people come to you
because you've got some really good good
games yeah I mean I think it's it's it's
amazing to see in the sort of maybe like
I guess almost now nine years since kind
of the indie games burst into the
mainstream with that first summer of
arcade on Xbox Live Arcade back on the
360 you know just watching the growth of
the industry has been fantastic and
watching the growth a Indies and of
course they're just like you know tons
of great developers out there and tons
of great options for them whether it's
you know working with a third-party
publisher working with a platform holder
you know for us an ID at Xbox we see our
job is just to make developers lives as
easy as possible you know we want to
make sure players have this great
variety of games and that means make
developers lives easy share as much
information with them as possible and
just you know and and and we'll get the
games and and so far it seems to be
working and obviously there's always
lots to do always working on improving
but you know just trying to be as you
know as true developers as we can and is
focused on making life easy for them as
possible it really seems to resonate it
and as a developer what's that like to
have you know this huge company like
Xbox who are right behind you like yeah
we oh that's great I mean like I mean
having that support I'm having like the
help and advice that they give us is
easily you know it's invaluable it
really is and now obviously this is like
your third game at this point but so
overcome yeah did mods and stuff in the
past connected to armor and king of the
kill what is it like now it's kind of
you've gone from strength to strength
you know your game is like the most
played thing on twitch right now you've
got like the backing of massive
companies how's that how's that been
it's pretty good no I mean I I'm really
like you mean I'm holding my celebration
like it's nice the success we've seen
you know we passed three million copies
sold on PC which is insane to me but you
know it's it's really it's I'll be happy
once we have a stable platform there for
games and then I'll celebrate you know
we have who still got month's work to do
you know on the game and Savoia and it's
the success is great but it's really
just you know made us batten down the
hatches
oh okay let's get this finished yeah I
was gonna say because with so many more
eyes on you
the pressure must be oh yeah I mean
we're but we're happy like we have our
plan you know where we have a really
strong development team like our
executive producer Chen Kim he he's just
a very clever man like you you've met
him and he's awesome he plans everything
down to like the finest detail and as a
result we've been able to do this
development that like a hero's pace I
was going to say like early access kind
of has almost a bad reputation these
days because some games can remain in
kind of a fluxed state for such a long
time but I've been playing your game for
a long time now it's it doesn't feel
like an access game it just it feels
like a finished product but well that
was our plan like I said like you know I
saw a lot of games go into early access
and I felt it was sort of like a poison
pill almost that you know that if you
say this people are immediately gonna
judge your game and it happens you know
it's natural but you know we want to
have a really stable game going into
early access you know because we're
using us like early access beta that
we're using it for optimization and
performance tuning and this kind of
stuff are you still holding true to that
original mantra of you will build
optimization
oh yes stability before adding like big
gameplay elements or things like
cosmetics I mean like will we have
focused on optimization so far we're
we're gonna be adding cosmetics after we
launch we may have to add in the system
in like a month or so before we go low
just to test it you know but in general
yet we're focused on optimization we're
focused on finishing the platform you
know and then we're worried about
monetization all that kind of stuff a
question I have been asked well
streaming myself and people have asked
will you keep the cosmetics you've
earned now when the game launches you
should do yeah there may be my nice cows
gonna say I'm gonna get the coat yeah
you'll be able to keep that all the way
through we may reset the points and
stuff like that but I have come here
very access but the skins we don't see
any reason to give away or take away is
with that coat why is that lauded so
highly it's yes like with $800 on Steam
right now what's the coat about I don't
know it's it's just a rare coat it's
like it was our pre-order you know we
had limited numbers and as a result it's
it's but this is what we want from our
skin economy is that you do have rarity
you do have that chance to get a great
skin from getting a case you know that
it's
I think it rewards people for playing
the game hurts my retirement fund
yeah sad my steam inventory just getting
healthier okay what was it like stepping
out on me on the stage the xbox press
conference nerve-racking as all hell
yeah ghillie suit I know
oh no it was great though because we
have like his name Dirk is it Dirk
someone with her uh he's like a speech
coach you know that we had four or five
rehearsals and you know it was all done
so clinically and so well that you know
I was really nervous it because the the
the the penultimate rehearsal they had
actually people sitting up front before
that it was just you were kind of doing
it to an empty hall that was fine and
then did we get to like people you're
like get nervous but then when I
actually did the thing just a huge sense
of relief you know it's going all I can
do is [ __ ] up
oh it's like that's all I can do I
didn't I would joke it memed no I was
happy no no big mistake you know it's
don't you mean it's like only advice you
can give anybody but it's great because
in the green room we had all the
speakers and you know when we're going
out big clap you know you can do it and
came back and and everyone did their
piece pretty much you know perfectly
there was no major screw-ups at all from
anyone which was was great yeah it's
awesome yeah so you're not really
releasing any you're just saying later
this year you know you're when it's
ready basically yeah exactly when were
we're happy with the build we have but
later this here is the plan but in terms
of other idea Xbox titles we've got
Tacoma coming out very soon yeah - come
on August 2nd cuphead fuzzy 49 September
29 I don't know which camera is supposed
to look at but yeah pre-order now
awesome we're super happy for those guys
and that game is just looking like
spectacular I still have to figure out
what what's the one escape from oh the
artful escape that game is have you guys
seen it I've not a better watch that
trailer and tried to figure out what
it's about
yeah amazing it's variable in the Xbox
booth energy like a just an unbelievable
journey games like a multiplayer board
movie yes yeah the game
it's snowboarding and air guitar right
something that might be fun for you
today we've got a player unknown
battleground playable booth downstairs
oh really
if you go downstairs and get chicken
dinner front of people it might be here
oh yeah you know I can't do that I would
fail you're not telling me you've never
got chicken dinner in your own game I
have but I've been carried by my team
that's the reason I got five yeah
exactly that's alright I don't mind I
don't mind carrying my teammates it's a
good chicken dinners chicken dinners oh
there it is oh yeah oh yes I remember
this cuz I thought it looked um like
double fine II actually yes it's from an
apprentice a publisher and those are a
great crew and the game is just like
it's impossible to play this demo
without like just having a huge smile on
your face and and like same with
watching the video it's just it's just
something really special about this when
I saw the trailer I was like is John
Lennon somehow made a game pretty much
Donnie galvatron so that's an incredible
name I might change my name to that you
can I'd give that another one that I
thought Lou criticals ashen yeah
Ashlyn's awesome from from Aurora 44
down in New Zealand like you know we
showed that a couple years ago on stage
I think I teased it a little bit
everybody got really excited those guys
have been heads down since then just
working on it and you look at this game
and the art is just unbelievable and
then what they're doing with just the
environment and then actually then you
start to play the game it's like holy
cow like this game is gonna be I think
this is really really something special
and and and super creepy and but it's
gonna be a really really fun title it
kind of looks like it has elements of
Dark Souls but is also kind of adding
the more presence of coop so yeah yeah
that's exactly right it's gonna have
it's definitely gonna have co-op in it
but it's definitely got that sort of
Dark Souls sort of vibe and I think it's
not going to be a super easy game to
play like I think it's gonna have some
challenge in there for players is that
the new idea Xbox mantra with you're
getting games are really hard to play
because blarin own you've got that I'm
just stressing everyone out now
cuphead yeah grounds is not hard to play
is how to win it's hard to win it's hard
to win however I do recommend camping is
a good
if you want to get it you know 20 - it
on a wind like I don't care many kills
yet if you came in second you still lost
you know it's like you know if you win
it doesn't matter how you do it you just
win
there is no bad strategy there is no
right way to play the game have you seen
the very outlandish strategies of some
of the players that been trying to do
different things like a pair won a game
about grounds without getting a kill yes
someone beats it by only using a car
mm-hmm are you expecting that the Xbox
players to kind of get even more insane
with it then oh yeah I think they're
gonna be some fun achievement design -
yeah yeah yeah I was just gonna I was
just gonna say there could be some some
fun to be had some fun name any
achievement titles we I was talking with
someone like that they were they had a
custom game of just pans and grenades
all right so that's all it was sounds
are gonna I love something well maybe we
should make the pan that it can deflect
grenades so you can back the grenade
away and play some you know grenades
unbel yeah bear canister yeah agree
that's a whole mode frying pans end game
loop that game I've been saved before by
being shot in the back and hanging off
my frying pan and that was like a ninja
commit by one of our developers he told
no one he was putting it in then the
next day was like see your ninja can
make up made the front page a PC gamer
and play okay Morris yeah you're kind of
embracing that that idea in your
development team being like just do
stuff that is gonna be kind of
outlandish but hey see if it works
oh yeah like we trust like our various
teams to kind of like if they they
believe in a good enough idea and they
bring it to us we'll run with it you
know it's like they were very much there
is no right way to do it it's like come
with an idea and if it works it works
has there been any ideas have been even
too outlandish that you've had to be
like alright well no I've had a few that
I've had to politely tell them why it's
not a good idea but uh give us a few
give us you oh no not just little things
like you know having the the blue zone
plays on in different shapes wait ah a
circle is good because it's balanced you
know having it like a octagon so if I
have to be dead diplomatic and kind of
go no no if you're stuck in the corner
of a square just behind go yeah right
okay thank you so much for coming on
we're very excited to play even more
play or enough
pounds that's basically yeah that's all
my computer's useful at this point
excited but thank you so much and make
sure you stay tuned here on the game
Sports dream we're going to be going to
the coop stage on the show floor at e3
were kind of funny going to be talking
to Marvel games hopefully about
spider-man stay tuned
you